Шановні колеги очевидно що росіянам не
маючи моша стати Україною доти поки
окупаційні війська щодня сьогодні
обстрілюють українські території
вбивають українців але в цьому питанні У
нас є дуже велика проблема тому що і для
української влади на жаль є список
хороших русских яких просто тут
приймають знаєте з караваями Ми хочемо
запитати офісу президента Ми хочемо
запитати в міністра культури що тут
роблять російська пропагандистка
Кремлівська Євгенія альбас яка ви не
просто подружка сімонян а виправдовувала
війну в Україні і зараз вона гастролює
Україною Ми хочемо запитати що тут
робить режисер Олександр молочников який
розбиті росіянами Бучі знімає фільм про
українських дітей і проводить кастинг де
не говорить про те що він російський
режисер Ми хочемо запи Та який це Суд
сьогодні повернув в ефір українських
телеканалів Сватів які насправді не
тільки гастролюють окупованим Кримом а й
виправдовують агресію тому вибачте будь
ласка не можна однією рукою говорити ні
фігшастать а друга і складати список
хороших русских давати їм громадянство і
запрошувати їх в Україну цьому має бути
покладенокрай також дуже важливо щоб ми
говорили про те як сьогодні
прикордонні території забезпечується
всім необхідним маємо дуже багато
сигналів від прикордонних областей від
прикордонників що сьогодні їм потрібно
більше зброї більше техніки і ми вітаємо
голосування сьогодні яке ми з вами
277 депутатів Верховної Ради повернули
30,000 е прикордонникам повернули 30
тисяч сьогодні всім збройним силам
України всім тим хто цього заслужений
пане Зеленський Шановний пане президенте
чекаємо Як нам най швидше підпис цього
важливого законопроекту Дякуємо всім
фракцій і тим слугам які